in 2014 I went to an archeological site
called Izapa and I was walking around
with the archaeologist who was
excavating there and she pointed out a
particular monument that she said that a
lot of Mormon tourists came to visit
because they felt that it represented a
scene from the Book of Mormon and I was
stunned I mean I just thought that was
very strange and really interesting and
it led me down this whole rabbit hole of
Mormon interests in archaeology at
Mesoamerica I'm Lizzy Wade and I'm a
contributing correspondent for science
magazine so what sort of the point that
everyone knows about the Book of Mormon
is that after Jesus's death and
resurrection he appears to inhabitants
of the Americas but actually there's
thousands of years of history around
that sort of centering on these
different tribes that come from the Near
East the Nephites and Lamanites the Book
of Mormon has some sort of vague
references to geography it talks about
an isthmus it talks about a major river
so people have you know looked for
correspondences between that geography
and the geography of the real world and
a lot of people believe that this narrow
isthmus that's discussed in the Book of
Mormon is Isthmus of Tehuantepec which
is the narrow part of Mexico and
particularly of interest here is the
state of Chiapas which is the
southernmost state of Mexico so after I
went to Izapa
and found out that there was Mormon
interest in the archaeology of southern
Mexico I just kept asking archaeologists
about it I eventually found the story of
the founder archaeological foundation
that continues to work in Mexico a man
named Thomas Stewart Ferguson who was a
Mormon and a lawyer in California he
never trained in archaeology but when he
was an undergraduate student at UC
Berkeley in the thirties he became
really interested in Mesoamerica and how
it related to the Book of Mormon
and he particularly became interested in
testing some ideas about where the Book
of Mormon took place and so he started
this archaeological foundation called
the new world archaeological foundation
that is headquartered in Chiapas even
today and is now under the umbrella of
BYU which is the Mormon University in
Utah so Ferguson you know went down to
Mesoamerica several times to sort of
look for these artifacts throughout the
50s he was very optimistic that proof of
the Book of Mormon was about to be
discovered literally any day that never
happened it hasn't it didn't happen
during his life and it hasn't happened
since and you know he sort of gradually
grew a little disillusioned it seems
like from his letters which I read and
in archives in Utah really what the
moment of true shift for him was when
the these Egyptian papyri that Joseph
Smith had translated into a scripture
called the Book of Abraham were
rediscovered at the met in New York when
he hired otologist
to translate these texts without telling
them anything about what he was hoping
to hear back from them they had said
these are thin tech ancient Egyptian
texts but they're from the book of the
dead which is basically the most common
text in that culture it's an all these
all the graves so from that Ferguson I
mean his faith seems to have immediately
disappeared I mean it was totally
undermined by this discovery so what's
special about the new world
archaeological foundation is that from
the time it was founded by Ferguson
really if it focused on a region and on
a time period that scientists really
hadn't been that interested in and that
region is sort of the middle and the
Pacific coast of Chiapas in the northern
part of Chiapas there are amazing Mayan
pyramids beautiful glyphs beautiful
ruins just incredible cities but in the
center and
so sort of the southern coast of Chiapas
you don't really get that this region
was particularly important right after
2000 BC this time period which is called
the formative period it's right when
people start settling down in villages
after being hunter-gatherers but this
the art you know the archeology
especially compared to like - the ruins
of - cities had been considered not that
exciting because it's a lot of
earthworks a lot of very early ceramics
so as this foundation and WAF directed
many really large-scale excavation in
the 50s and 60s the key sites are
chocolate at Corso Andi Zappa and thanks
to them we really know a lot about the
beginnings of civilization in
Mesoamerica and you know every gin that
turned out to be a very interesting
crossroads for a bunch of different
people
[Music]